(speaking in foreign language)
(inspirational music)
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Long considered
the caviar of the East,
bird's nests, or, more
specifically, the dried saliva
of swiftlet birds is a rare treat.
These birds prefer to build
their nests in dark caves,
and on Nabat Island in the Philippines,
nest-gatherers go to
great heights, literally,
to collect them.
(speaking in foreign language)
The work may be dangerous,
but these nest-gatherers
are willing to risk their lives because
the payoff is worth it.
(speaking in foreign language)
(thoughtful music)
Traditionally, the role of a nest-gatherer
is passed down from
generation to generation,
so while this may seem frightening,
for Angelito, it's an honor.
(speaking in foreign language)